hey this is fresh tile Walker in this
video I'm going to show how you can
calculate percentages in your head we'll
start out with an easy example of
calculating 10% the method is to move
the decimal point over one spot to the
left for the number 24 we move the
decimal point over one spot to the left
to find out that 10% is 2 point 4 in
another example the number 5 point 6 we
move the decimal point over one spot to
the left and that gives us 10% is 0.56
it's very easy to calculate 10% and that
will give us a method to calculate 15%
we first calculate 10% and then we add
half of 10% to itself in the number 24
we start out by calculating 10% by
moving the decimal point one spot over
and now we take half of that so half of
2 point 4 is 1 point 2 and we add these
two numbers together to get us 15% which
is 3 point 6 now this may sound
complicated and look complicated but
trust me if you practice you'll get very
good at it and you'll be able to
calculate 15% in your head for the
number 5 point 6 we calculate 10% by
moving the decimal point one spot over
and now we have to take half of 0.56 and
we can do this easily as 0.28 so to get
to 15% we add these two numbers together
and we get that 15% is 0.8 4
to calculate 50% we simply take a number
and divide it in half we divide it by 2
so 24 we can divide that by 2 to get 12
and 5.6 we can divide that by 2 to get
2.8 will build on this to calculate 25%
which is we're going to divide the
number in half two times so when we
start out with 24 we first divide it in
half to get 12 and then we divide it in
half once more to get 6 and that'll be
25%
similarly for 5.6 dividing in half one
time gives us 2.8 and we can easily
divide that number one time more to get
1.4 as 25% combining these two methods
we can calculate 75% by adding 50% and
25% together
so what's 75% of 24 we first calculate
50% by taking half then we calculate 25%
by taking half once more and to get to
75% we add these numbers together 12
plus 6 is 18 we do the same thing for
5.6 half of the number is 2.8 we take it
half of that number to get 1.4 and to
get 75% we add these two numbers
together which is 4.2
60% to calculate 60% we're going to
build on a couple of the things we've
done already we need to calculate 50%
and then add that to 10% so to calculate
60% of 24 we first calculate 50% which
is 12 then we calculate 10% by moving
the decimal point over and we add these
two numbers together to get 60% is 14
point four four five point six we first
calculate 50% by taking 1/2 then we
calculate 10% by moving the decimal
point over and finally we add the two
numbers together so we get that 60% is
three point three six for 40% it's a
very similar process we calculate 50%
and then we subtract out 10% so our 50%
and 10% are going to be the same numbers
but in our final step to get to 40% we
subtract the two so we get that nine
point six is 40% of 24 for 85% this will
be the most complicated example we're
doing we're going to calculate 15% and
subtract that number from the whole so
how do we calculate 15% first we
calculate 10% by moving the decimal
point over then we take half of that
number
so you're 2.4 and 1.2 so 15% is the sum
of these two which is three point six
and to get to 85% we need to subtract
that from the original number
so 24 minus 3.6 is twenty point four and
that's 85% the lesson in all of this
video is that you should practice on
taking 10% and dividing numbers in half
because all of the examples we've done
here are combinations of those two steps
I hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel you can catch me
on my blog mind your decisions or
on twitter at pressure Walker